Okay. So this of course is our second session.
and unlike the
first session
this we're going to go deeper into mathematics. So we
are going to take our time.
to develop
our mathematical proficiency
Let me tell you what we are going to be to doing today.
Okay, so I'm going to pull up the agenda.
Today, which is the 29th of June.
We are going to begin first.
with a
very short
review
of set
builder notation
so not set theory set builder notation.
Review of set builder notation. Why?
because
any book that you pick up?
on linear algebra
is going to use a lot of
abstract algebra terminology
the foundation of which is set theory.
So what I'm trying to say is we're going to learn I'm going to show you the
basics of set builder notation, which is really simple.
And then once we're all on the same page, we will then
proceed to talk about some fundamentals of abstract algebra.
Remember?
Abstract algebra and linear algebra are not separate.
linear algebra depends on abstract algebra, so
we will talk about abstract algebra to the extent
that will allow us to
You know talk a linear algebra.
And then once we have done, so
You know, once we have I've shown you the basics of abstract algebra
also have clarified for you some terminology.
And showing you the syntax.
We could quite literally pick up a textbook. I have a several of
these on my on my shelf, but for example
this one.
Right or many others and we can just jump right
into the middle.
And then understand what?
that topic is
in our first session and we will do that together.
Of course.
We're going to do exercises.
Because it is one thing for you to watch.
And instruct your talk about something.
And we know why I explained it. It might make sense to
you because I'll have the answers. All right in front of you.
but the best way to
Learn or to ensure that you've absolutely absorbed
everything that has been communicated to is to do exercises.
So we're going to do an exercise.
on
let me just call it the linear algebra, but there
are different aspects right there. Is this systems of equations part there
is the Matrix operations part.
There is a set representation part and then there's even the visualization part
right which we are going to do by the we want to be able to plot
points on a Cartesian coordinate
system.
and two three dimensions
so we want to talk about the
directions of vectors
which you will do as well.
and then
if time allows it, let's see how this session will go
we want to do we're going to do a
review of
systems of equations
and then do it exercise on it.
If we don't get to the fifth part.
I want to at least take you through the numpy array.
after all this
Course is based on python, right? We want
to learn a linear algebra and then Implement what we know in Python.
Because later on we want to see how we can use linear algebra
techniques.
For examples in economics in transportation
and big part of his neural
networks. We talked about this. Okay. Now let me all say
this to you.
Because none of these courses assume
prerequisites me. There's no admission criteria, right?
I sometimes adjust
the pace of the classes.
Okay, so if I see that I'll it's too
much. We slow it down. We take our time and if
everyone is familiar with if more people are familiar with the concept,
but the concepts we can speed it up.
Okay, so which is why I say, let's see how it goes.
Very well.
Now we want to one thing that we
should have checked ideally is making sure that everybody
has Python and you put a notebook installed.
Hello, let me ask you this. How many of you have?
You put a notebook on your machines at this time.
If you do type in wife why for yes, otherwise type
it in. I just want to quickly gauge.
And preparedness. So Richard says yes. Now that says yes.
How about you no one Richard Ron?
Okay, it's that's okay.
We're not going to do much of.
Python Programming and at least out of the
session I'm gonna show you some ideas, but we're not going to do program
right now, but I just keep in mind that there will
be an assignment.
Using Jupiter notebook
the numpyre library and matplotlib.
Because if you remember in session what we we plotted the constraints.
Of our LP problem our linear program problem.
So you you want to do the same?
For the assignment, okay.
All right.
Let's begin with the first item. Excuse me.
and as usual you want to
Look on the right pedal because I'm gonna write latex code
on the left. So you want to see the results here on the right?
Okay.
And then you make sure when this is recorded.
it doesn't block the
results
Okay.
so
review of set
Theory
Set builder notation not set theory.
and the mathematics
sets all represented with
curly brackets
now we have
Specific types of sets but I'll come down in a moment.
So for example, this is a set.
One two three, right? We have a set with three elements.
One, two, three, we use those words.
And we can use a letter to represent it. So we have to set a
with elements 1 2 3
no.
a vector
maybe not jump ahead too quickly. Let's let me call this a vector
space because we're going to come this in a moment.
And also if so, this is
a set we call its these numbers in here. Yeah, it's
elements and if we want to use such
polar notation.
Let me actually show your set builder notation.
Say we have the set.
Let's do a again.
This time using set builder we can say x such
that.
X is an integer
X such that X
Is an integer.
and
X is between
one and three
so
X
l EQ
so what we're doing what this?
Expression is saying is producer set with elements X.
So we're going to have these x's in this set.
Such that the x is our integers.
I'll tell you what this Z is in a second if it's not clear
if you haven't seen this before.
Add X's between one and three.
So, of course we have the number system. Let me take let me go up one
level.
And this is we will come to this in a moment. We will return to this
topic once we get to abstract algebra the number systems.
So we have the natural numbers, for example.
Which are indicated with the letter n?
You can see that there is this.
like two lines
So it's not just a normal the capital letter and
it's it looks like that.
And this is the this is the set of numbers.
from
1 2
until n
but these are all of course.
now their whole numbers
so no.
The whole there's no fraction.
and of course, they are not signed so
no positive or negative.
This is the natural numbers.
I won't do all of them just a few of them. So you get the idea and then
we have the integers.
Which is like the natural numbers, but they also go on the negative side.
So we have negative 1.
negative 2 Etc
Okay.
Should have put here Infinity.
minus
Okay.
And then we have the real numbers. This one will be
definitely want to know because
the real numbers are always.
denoted in linear algebra, and that
is just a set of
rational and irrational numbers
so the numbers like pi and E.
Oil is number. These are irrational numbers.
Because they are not repeating and then we have the rational numbers.
Okay, so we won't get to the complex number system or
this is sufficient. So if you
see
letters that look like this they have
this line Crossing through
the letter.
Then we talking about a number system. So down here.
What are we saying?
We are saying that a
Again, as a set containing elements
X such that this vertical bar is pronounced.
Or it's red as such that alternatively we
can use a colon in here like so.
So these are interchangeable.
So X such that X is an integer.
And it is between one and three including
one and three.
Okay.
Now now that we know what we've done this quick review of
such let's talk about
a vectors
so of the word space
Really means set.
So why not just say Vector set instead of vector space?
because spaces imply some
sort of
some rules apply
There are some ordering there are some operations you
can apply to the elements on the set. So we try
to be more specific.
and
we also want to be careful well.
There's another word here. I want to use element.
Okay, so they would element.
In the in the context of linear algebra.
we
the convention is not to use the word element in a set.
The convention is to use the word.
Well the scalar.
The scalars of a set so in linear
algebra and element can be called scalar.
or point
or
component
and it's unlikely free to see a little bit. So we see these all the
elements elements are all.
synonyms
for members of a
matrix
and of course a vector is a type of Matrix.
Okay, so these words are interchangeable.
Okay.
So we can call this point point.
or a component component component
element element scalar scalar scalar
Interchangeable, unfortunately, that's how it is in mathematics. They
use different words to refer to
the same thing.
We don't.
use curly brackets
or curly braces the convention is to use either parentheses.
or
square brackets
both are interchangeable.
Okay, let me pull up my notes.
Run asks, which version of python anything version
through your above? Okay. Let me pull up
the
my notes very quickly. Here we go in your algebra.
Okay.
So what is a vector space?
a vector space
actually, no, hold on. I I don't want to jump this is
this is supposed to be vector.
So
vectors
are sets of
elements
however
vectors
are conventionally referred
to
as spaces with scalars
Okay.
now
and of course
we use lowercase letters to indicate them. So
like so
and they will either come.
with an arrow on over them like so
Or like I said in our first session it could be they
could be bold like so.
Okay.
so we call the number either scalars or components of
the vector
Okay.
we also want to talk about
a linear span linear combination
row space and column space
So we have a linear combination.
And then we can do an exercise.
combination
then we will do.
linear span
and the column space
and then the row space.
And before we do this, we'll also talk about matrices.
so we want to
be clear with our
terminology
Okay.
Now, let me come to Vector space. Let me actually borrow it
from the chapter of this book because I thought I'd written it here.
a vector space
okay.
You want 50?
Whenever I'll tell you what?
The books that we we are using here.
Okay.
Just give me a second.
And then one of the exercises we're going to do is Implement these
with numpy. I turn two vectors
into numpy arrays.
And then perform arithmetic operations on them 1 1
2.
So for how many of these were already where you
already familiar with if you've if you if you already know what the if
you've seen this before if like, you know what they are typing why otherwise also
type in
Let's gauge.
your familiarity
Okay.
super
Now I'm going to type here the definition of vector space.
But then to probably understand we will have to return to
abstract algebra.
Okay, we'll have to visit our abstract algebra. So see
it says here.
That a vector space. So let me just type in definition and
then
I'll clarify a vector space.
is
Okay, let's say it says V.
on a minute
Yeah is a vector space over the field K Over
the field?
Okay.
And then we have the axioms which with the following axioms.
the X seems are
addition and multiplication
vector addition
Factor multiplication, so let me pause pause over
here and turn the abstract algebra in a
moment. No one else. How do we differentiate the concept of row vector
and column Vector using the notation?
I don't believe there's a notation for
expressing at least our letters
Unless of course you do something like, you
know, you put a line break. You have like
a long square bracket.
or you have a
like basically either
see write the sequence of numbers and sequence of
components or scalars.
Horizontally and that becomes a row or you do it vertically
you get a color.
But if you're looking at a letter and you want to know if this is a row
or column you have to know from the from the context from the
text surrounding it.
Okay, here we have it says that a vector space fee over
the field.
What does over mean and what this field mean?
So let's
pause here. I'm gonna open another document to talk
about abstract algebra a little bit.
So this will be
abstract
tutorial one
Okay.
so
I say this will take about 15 or so minutes.
But I mean if you if you do not have exposure to abstract algebra.
This would this is going to take you along. This will
take you very far.
Later on when you I don't know.
Want to read more advanced probability or go into something called
The Measure Theory.
Knowledge of abstract algebra will be super beneficial.
So let's begin.
The document is tutorial 7,
which is also on the dashboard, okay?
I will begin with.
So number six the total number six.
on the dashboard
All right.
so you will begin with something called a
binary operation
Okay.
so this is
abstract
algebra tutorial
binary operation a binding operation
Is some sort of arithmetic operation that he can
apply to the elements of a set.
For example addition and multiple equation are both examples
of binary operations.
Okay, so let's establish this terminology
binary operation.
and then we have
our first
special type of set an abstract algebra, which
we call the group.
A group can we express?
as the Tuple and again Tuple is a set set curly,
but it's
Okay, not pull it three
elements. You would say a triple or three three people
or four tubular five tuples. So however many elements you have in that
set. You say number two pull.
Okay.
G is the set
and here the star indicates the bunny
operation so can be multiplication or addition.
well, we don't we
if there are some certain rules.
We don't use the word it's quite vague. And these
are the axioms that apply to the group
group. By the way. The group is a foundation will build
on top of so other types of sets and abstract algebra are
variations of groups.
We first have something called closure.
What does closure mean?
Closure means that if you were to perform a binary operation on
the elements of the set.
The outcome would be another element that also belongs
to the set.
So let me actually change this to G.
Okay.
What's an example of?
such a
rule
the integers
if we take two integers or let's keep it
simple if you take the natural numbers.
Add them together you will get another natural number.
So 5 plus 5 gives you 10 which isn't which is still an
element within the natural numbers.
Multiply them you will also get another element.
but then division doesn't apply because if you divide
for example
4 over 5 the result is not going to be division. So that
operation does not apply to that set.
Okay.
So there's closure then there's identity.
And identity says that there exists a number.
Such that when you multiply it.
By any of the elements in that set you get
the element again.
So here what number could that be if you were
talking about the
the integers
What number if we multiply it with
any element would give us the same number. So for example, let's say a
is 5.
A times what will give you five?
The number one. So here I stands for then and this
is a unique element.
This is a unique element exactly. What?
So it the identity says that there
exists a number such that multiply by an element of the
set, you know, you get you get the same number and then there is inverse.
Okay.
We'll see an example of this but there's a number.
the
if you have a number and you multiply
it by its inverse.
You will get the that unique identity identity element.
And then there's associativity.
It says that well, for example, if you're doing multiplication
multiplying eight B times C
and then multiplying it by a it is will give you the same.
Result if had you done 8 times B then
times C this associate associated.
So abstract algebra.
When we have words like groups Rings Fields Etc
such and I'm going to show you the others.
works this way
you have a set.
To which some specific actions apply
and then if you add or remove axioms you
then get another set. So for example, we have something called a billion group.
a billion group
a billion group. Does anyone know the synonym for the a billion
group?
And you know anyone know.
there was
a problem with these synonyms. I mean exactly a commutative
group.
commutative commutative
and what why is it called the commutative because
we have axioms one to four plus a fifth.
Axiom
Which is commutative.
simply means if you multiply 8 times B is the same
thing as multiplying B times a
Now, of course, we will come across certain sets in linear
algebra where this is not the case.
because for example if you want to multiply a row by a matrix
What am I saying? A vector multiplied by matrix? You
cannot turn them around.
So what is it in if you want to multiply a
vector with a matrix the number of columns must
match the number of rows.
So you can't just commit them around it's not
the same thing. Okay.
But anyway, this is not specific to vectors and
matrices is just
It can apply to different types of sets different types
of mathematical objects.
And then we have a ring.
We just copy paste the whole.
Set of axioms.
You'll see what I'm going with this in a very shortly.
We haven't we have the ring.
A set to which the following actions apply you have associativity for
addition.
Commutativity for addition there
is a zero element.
So there's an element. This is incorrect.
By the way plus 0 is a
A plus zero is it?
Okay.
There is added inverse.
So similar to what we saw with the group, there's an element
the inverse of which will give you.
That won't give us identity. This one gives us zero they
cancel for here. In addition. They cancel each other out we of
course have associativity. This is from multiplication. So associatively
in committee commutativity for addition and the
same for multiplication and then there's Unity
Like with groups and then there is the
distributive law.
Then there is a special type of ring.
Called the integral domain.
And this is
a set. It's the type of ring. It is a set. Of course.
Well the axioms 128 but not seven.
So Unity does not apply to an integral domain.
Then there is the field. This is the word we encountered
when we're talking about linear algebra.
So linear algebra.
Is a type of ring.
With axioms 1 to 8 that has all
eight Axiom plus a ninth axis the
multiplicative inverse.
That's what it field is.
Now, I really don't know where these names came from
ring. I remember remember seeing a
very fascinating page.
And there was illustration about it forming a ring.
I don't remember unfortunately, but the
names in my opinion, they're not very intuitive.
Like why field?
you know, it did not helpful but
That's how it is.
now
so I hope it's clear. What I feel is right a field is a set
with
or I should say to which these rules apply.
That seems our rules. So this is the active
means something that is true for all the elements
of that set.
Okay, so to all of the elements in a ring,
you can apply these rules. This is this is true
why this is what why is why is even helpful because
these axioms will help will
give you confidence.
That whenever you apply such operations to any element of
the set you can be sure.
It will it will hold?
If you're doing things like proofs or if you're from deleting
a model axioms will really help you
get to a solution faster. Anyway, that is
so a fear. That's basically a ring, but we also have
a ninth Axiom the multiplicative inverse.
so
we will see examples of vectors when
you multiply by its inverse. You will
get the original vector.
This is not something you can do to objects.
In the in the let's say integer number system.
Okay.
So let's return back to this.
Linear algebra tutorial so it says what a vector space V
again the word space means set all
the field K with the following exam. So basically when
we see over we mean the elements in this field are
put in that set.
Okay, so we have
a vector addition
which means if you add
the elements in this set
They have two vectors now here. They don't use
the arrow, but I'm going to use it because
it's very important that you
do so
Okay, so actually scalars.
So have you plus b in?
uppercase V
Yes, so we have two elements.
in a vector
the it's addition the addition of these two elements.
the addition of these two elements
would give you another component inside the vector.
And then there is more Vector multiplication.
which is the same thing, but
multiplication
use times
and if we return to abstract algebra.
We set a field is a type of ring.
And I did not indicate it here, but even closure applies to
to rings.
Okay.
So this is a wood will encounter a great deal.
Let me now show you.
A linear combination what is linear combination?
linear combination
and let me talk about our
to the power n what does this mean?
R to the power
dollars
Does anyone know what this what this what this means? So for example,
if you have something like this?
let's say
to the power 3
What does this mean?
What could this mean?
any ideas
This is something you will see everywhere three
dimensional space.
XYZ axis Yeah, so basically
you will get a set.
let's use the word space to be consistent with
linear algebra terminology with
Any three letters?
Any three?
elements or components
or points since the one using XYZ any points
all of which belong inside the real numbers system
such that such that
A B C all of them are in
r or the real number
system
Okay. So for example, this could be a point in
a three-dimensional space.
Or it could just be a vector.
if you remember in
okay, maybe you're not all there, but it doesn't necessarily have
to be a point on a coordinate space. It just
could be a set with three elements in it.
So that's what this this means.
So for example art to the power 5 same thing a b c.
d
This should be our.
Okay, so here it says we have so now
that we know what that is.
the linear combination
a linear combination is let's say we have vectors.
And here I'm using the Bold errors V2 from V1 to
VK, by the way when I see n or k or some
subscript like that either pick the number three or the number
five.
Helps me visualize things. So let's say we have
five vectors. This is a vector 1 2 3 4 5 all of
them are for example three in three
dimensions.
So this is a set with three points. This is a set with
three points.
And even the fifth Vector is a set.
with three points or three
components or three elements
and
associate with each Vector was a constant.
Which are real numbers so we can see there's no
superscript here because these are scalars.
So what's an example of a linear combination something that looks like this?
I will use.
The letter L.
So we will take
the vectors
I'll just do to I'll just do three.
two and three
Okay, but we're going to add that together.
but to each vector
we multiply the constants.
So Alpha sub 1 will be multiplied by the first
vector.
And then here we have the second vector.
and of course the third Factor
evaluate this expression.
And you have your linear combination?
Now what's a linear span?
a linear span
is the following
Say we have a vector space.
Basically as a set of vectors A set
containing vectors.
And we have let's say five vectors.
five vectors
Let me keep of this.
Okay.
Then the linear span.
And let me copy this bit. Let me make sure I think I'm missing
one letter. Let me double check this.
Make sure I got all the letters, right?
so we have
yeah, this was supposed to be X.
and
these are supposed to be
I was I meant to do this I made to make these bold to
make these vectors.
Let me deliver quickly. It's just to be avoid any
mistakes.
Yes, yes.
Okay.
Ron says given a vector space given given so
a given.
Given a vector space. I don't need to capitalize these words.
I have to be careful with the
But how I spell?
So we have a space.
a vector space V
what elements?
V1 V2 all the way to VK
and then we put these vectors inside a
set called X.
Okay, so we take these sequence of values. So they're all
vectors. We put them inside it says inside the set X.
If we apply this linear this linear span function
to X.
Then we will get the following.
We will get a set of the linear
combinations. So that's what a linear span is. A linear span is
a set of linear combination if you remember from we talked
about self-brother notation.
We said that.
A this is well, and
this is a set.
with these elements
Well, actually this is not an element. This is an X. This is the evaluation of
expression.
Such that these are
vectors.
And these are the constants.
So linear span is a set of linear
combinations. So it's basically a set of these.
That's what a linear span is.
Okay.
Made a column space and roast
space are quite simple. Why do we get a very close to Gilbert strengths
for Big Ideas, right if you remember in
session one I told you about
Gilbert strengths for fundamentals. There's a
video on YouTube MIT course where we talked
we starts discussion aligning algebra with these
four special spaces these four special sets. They're
all space the column space
the null space and I think something called the
left knelt space. I I need double check the fourth one.
But a matrix, you know a matrix, I mean, you
know what it looks like.
We've already seen it.
matrices are denoted like
so
so for example
to the power and
times that
so for vectors, we have raised
to one particular power that will give us a sequence of
an element so five elements in one set and a
matrix obviously is a set of sets.
So it can be a set with five
elements in three rows.
So what this could look something?
like this
but
small
Matrix
oh, let me just copy from the other tutorial.
Where's the Matrix?
Here we go.
Now, this is a square Matrix. So let me make it.
not Square
So in matrices do we indicate the number of rows first or
the number?
of columns
I think this is something I always keep forgetting. So what would n be
here?
What would NB here?
And what would M be?
So n is the number of rows so we have two rows and three.
So that's what we mean by by.
you know R to the power n times m
two rows
with three columns
and I hope you can be you know, it's probably self-explanatory. What
a column space is. We said we've already established that
there was space being set.
So the column space for the Matrix, let's
indicate this Matrix with the letter m.
Okay. Once again, we want to make sure
it's bold letter. So PF.
So the economic space of M would be what that sets of
columns.
so it will get a vector 2 6 a vector 1/5
of vector one negative 3
and then the row space would be well two one one and six five negative
three.
That's it.
That's all the row space and column space are.
So we would get this.
So they're all space.
So, this is our Matrix m.
I think this was for the null space. This is incorrect. I'll come back to this later
on. They're all spaces the how can
I do I'll make it? Okay, let me do this very quickly so we get
let's you set builder notation, right so we will get
a set of vectors
such that.
V
Is a column.
It's color.
of
the Matrix m
and of course, this is supposed to
be real sorry and of course column space would be all of
the
the sets that make up the row in in The
Matrix sound.
Okay, so, oh we will use
this glossary.
So that we can you know easily.
Talk about anything to with matrices neural networks.
3D plots
And every time we use words like this, we know what we're talking about.
All right.
So I think you most of you said you have
let me just double check your answers. So yeah, when I asked if you all have
no pandas installed.
Ron you said no. Okay run. I'll
tell you where you can do this exercise.
You can there's an online compiler where you
can just write your code.
I think everybody else has Python and stuff again.
I'll give it here's what I'll do with the exercise. I'll give
you I'll write the exercise.
If you can do it on your laptop on in your
own ID, perfect. Otherwise, I'll give you a link to the online compiler. You
can do the solution there.
Okay.
comment in the chart
I have Python 3, that's fine. You don't
need we don't we don't need you Jupiter notebook. We want just for comments not
in comments to
Because we're going to be using my numpy and math
plot lib, and so you'll be writing.
Series of Snippets so it just makes
it easier to see your code progress and
actually visualize it. So for now you don't we don't need it.
Okay.
For now, you don't need it.
Let me switch to the
slack Channel
to write the exercise.
Okay.
exercise
one
P exercise by the way, while I'm running this does
it do any of you have any questions?
Because I've been talking 15 minutes straight 15 minutes straight without
asking any quick with that leg asking questions.
If you have any questions, let me know while I type the exercise.
Hey Danny. Hey there Ron your example
for the linear space.
The second term had subscripts of one for
those supposed to be twos.
and then your space
what I mean linear span, I'm sorry.
about the bottom equation
Yes.
Okay, okay. I see perfect. Thank you.
So this should be
to one video
Thanks.
And I should also make these gold. I'll fix that.
Okay, so for this one.
You want to create three?
vectors in Python
essentially a list or you can even use
two poles to do this
Create three vectors and python.
over
and I'm going to use linear algebra terminology.
are
Yeah.
to the power
and where
n is equal to 5.
Okay.
And call or declare.
these
vectors
with
you know, we sub 1 V sub 2 V sub 3
so in Python, we use something called snake notation.
As opposed to camera case like notation is when you deliver
it.
characters or variable or even functions with underscore instead
of
complicating them
put the vectors.
V sub 1 V sub 2 V sub 3
oops
inside the Matrix
math PF
M.
and this would be
so we have
Each Vector has five.
Components and we have three vectors. So that's three.
times five
and you want to declare this Matrix?
declare
let's Matrix.
with
See, here's the problem in Python. We use uppercase letters
for classes.
not
yeah, we don't use uppercase that is because it meant for classes, but
and well, let's take the lower class big lower
clusters because we cannot violate Python Programming conventions.
and then for number three
convert
the
Matrix
to a numpy
Array, how do you do this using the code?
NP dot array
the method
so there's a difference you but you cannot you cannot perform.
Matrix operations on python lists
not unless you you write a function to implement them,
but you can do this with a numpy array. So if you
have two numpy arrays, you can add them as if they were two vectors. I mean,
that's what the library is built for.
and then finally
add the
elements
of the row space
of
M.
Remember the word space.
means set
so we're talking about the set of elements.
So if
It's a space of a matrix then the
elements of a matrix could only the row space
of a matrix can only be three vectors.
So I might suggestion is
see if we can do the first two. I just want to see if everybody's clear
on the terminology so far and then you can attempt to
do three and four.
Okay, let me add a note here.
For number three, you need to import.
Numpy and you can do this.
With this code so it would go import.
NP and numpy as MP
Okay.
so I'll
take a screenshot of this exercise. I'll put this on
Slack.
And I'll give you the link to the python interpreter.
So this is
exercise
one
see the screenshot.
Alright, here's the picture.
Solve the or complete the steps.
steps in the exercise
and then please submit your file.
What you want to name exercise?
- 1.py to me privately, so don't post it
in the main Channel.
Okay.
let me tell you where you can do the exercise if
you don't have
Notebooking The Notebook install
because you also need the pandas library, right? They're not my library.
So
you could use call app which is both a notebook and it already has numpy pre-installed.
so you can if you
don't
have
either numpy
or Jupiter installed
you can use Google call that which is free.
You don't even have to create an account.
Pretty straightfor you go to collab.
The link I just gave you.
You choose new notebook.
new notebook
and then you can use the code. I just showed you.
So we'll come over here.
And then you would go.
import numpy
as NP and then can carry on. So
for example if you want to create an array.
And not pyre you would go and pay array and then you would
put your list.
And just like that.
We need to make sure we run this right?
And just like that you have created yourself a vector.
Okay, this would be for example Visa 1.
So let's find out.
10 minutes on this exercise
and then we'll look at the solution together. By the way for next
session. What I'll do is in the dashboard. I'm going
to add.
a web page a document
in with instructions on setting up pythons setting up
Jupiter notebook setting up vs code. I recommend use vs code.
Excuse me use vs code if you're doing this locally.
and of course how to install these libraries
there are two ways to start you put a notebook. One
of them is to install a separately install the server separately.
Then there's a plugin vs code, which you just click
on install and it's there.
Okay, so what we'll do that in the next session, but you definitely
want to do this because we are gonna like I said, this course is based
on Python and the numpy library. So you want to make sure you have already
before Friday's session. Okay everybody.
So here's the exercise.
10 minutes I will look at this. We'll look at the solution together
and let me also give you the glory for reference.
I'll generate it here.
You know just second.
Here's the glossary for your reference.
See this PF.
here
you
So do you want to see this solution or do you want more time? If you
want to see the solution type in s if you want more time
type in t?
Anybody else?
Okay, so four more minutes for more minutes, I will look at the solution.
I'll be with you in one second.
Hi Richard, if you want to submit the file.
Just click on my name.
And then send message.
So I can't I don't think I can send myself a message,
but just click on my icon my profile.
And then you'll have the option to send me direct message and then attach the
file attach your solution file.
and by the way
I have to download the notebooks re-upload them. So I'll give
feedback on the exercises after the session
is over just faster fine.
Do it that way.
Okay.
mark
So, thank you Rich for the file.
so, um
is it better to
upload P Wi-Fi files or the or that
you put a notebook file? Oh nice. Okay.
The notebook is fine. All right, but yeah, I'll
give feedback after the session is over so
at common
Okay, should we look at the solution now?
If I can ask everyone to send in your
files.
so even if you're not done with the
solution
It helps me see the solution be helps me to see you
know, what part wasn't clear and then so I can emphasize on
it either in the next session or by maybe recording
separate videos. So please everybody if you haven't sent in
your files send them now.
It's very important Cuba Lawrie. Neela.
Private if you haven't if anyone ran Richard.
If you haven't said in your face, please do so now.
I just said what whatever you have.
Just dump it dump it in the stock Channel.
Let's get the solution together.
Okay, I will go to collab.
And let's do this solution.
Okay.
so I'm going to
But the side by side so we can see the requirements.
And the code next to each other.
Yes.
Please everybody do send your files because that you know,
it will help make the subsequent sessions more
effective.
Okay.
So here we have numpy imported which means we can
use.
We can work with.
A vectors and multi-dimensional arrays. So right now we're
looking we will look at the NP dot array. There's something called NP in
the array.
The numpy library is quite
comprehensive. So we're going to go through
it go through its different features.
You know.
and in each session
So here it says number one create three vectors.
over RN
Where n is equal to 5.
so 5 dimensional vectors
and declare these with v sub 1 V sub 2 V sub
So what would V sub 1 look like it would have V sub 1?
And this would be equal to I'm just going to put any five
networks. I'm going to go one two.
three four five
okay, so this
Is all real numbers remember the set
of natural numbers are subset
of the set of real numbers.
So these are all.
Well, that's that's an example of one vector.
over RN
and then V2 could be.
Seven eight nine.
ten seven eight nine Tenors going up any ground
increments of one no particular reason for me to use these numbers just
Any random number will do.
And then we have V3.
so 12 13
15 16. There we go.
So that's how we create.
three
vectors
and this is for number two put the vectors inside the
Matrix m.
That is a three by three by five Matrix. How do
we create a matrix that has three file three by five?
So if you want to create a matrix.
Yeah, that's again. Just a multi-dimensionalistant python.
so what I'm just going to do is I'm going to remember a
matrix is a
is a is rows of vectors A
Matrix is a rows of vectors. That's one
way to look at it either Columns of rows.
Columns of vectors or rows of vectors here we
have
we'll go with rows. So this is row number one.
Which is a vector?
so these are all subsets of
the row space of them
Okay, so V2.
And then V 3.
And now we have ourselves a matrix if I now type in m.
There you can see.
if you use a math lab this
I mean the coding approach would be very
familiar.
Oh, by the way, if you want to work with math lab discourse will help
you out a great deal. Maybe I can
I'll add I'll add Snippets.
For master so we won't cover Matlab in the course, but I'll give you
the Matlab implementation of the Python code that
we're doing.
Matter, of course stands for Matrix laboratory if I
remember correctly.
Anyway, so now we have a matrix which is a
set of three subsets of three elements where
each element is itself a vector.
So that's element 1 element 2 element 3. How do
we turn this thing into an array
we go NP dot array.
And then you plug in your list.
I'm gonna go ahead and put
m in there
Now, of course I could have made these numpy erased first and then
put them in but the order doesn't matter not Pi will take care of it.
So let me add some comments in here. We will declare.
three vectors
over r
and then declare the Matrix m
which is
2 by 3
and then here I'm just previewing The Matrix preview The Matrix.
Okay.
Oh, excuse me, three by five.
Yes 3.5.
Okay. Yeah three rows.
of elements for each element is a
space of five components or
five elements
And then here we are going to convert The
Matrix.
M.
M to
a numpy
multi-dimensional
well, that's actually not malt. It's actually affect It's actually an array
with three elements. So
an Empire rate
now, how do we get the
first element of the row space of them
Run us. Can I assume there's an NP method to do
step 4 there are but I'm gonna keep it simple. So for example if
I want the first row.
I'm just going to go and
zero, it's gonna give me the first Vector inside
the Matrix.
M.
Okay, and then exactly I can use I
can use square bracket notation. If I want to add these three vectors together for
four number step number four. So add
the elements of the row space. What are the elements of the of
the row space?
They are M sub M 0 and 1 and M2.
And here's the thing in programming we start our
subscripts from zero so we come from 0.
So this would be the first Vector second Vector third vector.
and then if you want to add them together, well, we just do just not biologically
add them together like so
and we can call this the what should
we call this?
This will be V sub 4 remember what
we said about the vector space we said.
It is addition.
The close reaction applies to it under
addition. So if you add the if you
add two vectors together, you get a third Vector. That's what closures and
you will see now if I add these together
And I say V sub 4.
V sub 4
why is it stuck?
That was not supposed to happen. Why why let's see.
What are you wrong?
these sub4
the numpy in the area overrides the plus operator. Is
that a question or is that a statement?
Iran
No, no, I did. I just did the solution. I literally the
solution before I
started this
what am I doing wrong?
Oh, okay. So yes, the question is yes, it does.
let me see why I'm getting a combination of
lists
Maybe I missed a code and here. Ah, yes. They just
made a mistake. I did convert.
I did convert M to a numpy array, but
I did not reassign it so I'm gonna reassign it. Okay, so m
is gonna go from being a python listen to now being a
numpy array. Okay. I was missing this bit. So one
more time.
Now I'm going to create a fourth Vector out of the sum of
these vectors. And if I now say V4 there you
can see we've done.
vector addition
and that's
the answer.
now, this is very nice because
we can go.
Almost seamlessly from math expression to python
implementation. And then later on when we
look at examples of you know, graphing vectors and three-dimensional
space.
And one of the things I really want to show you is cosine similarity.
this little
function
is so useful if you want to let's say if you're doing
text.
natural language processing
or
you know how when you know how when you Google a term in in
Google?
and then
you you misspell the word.
So Google gives you a suggest award.
It is very close. So let's say I type in the word Apple, but I
type APLE
And the Google Source did you mean Apple?
It does that.
so one way to to see how
or to find a close approximate for
the user's query is to use cosine similarity.
And it uses one part of one
one of the components maybe not
use that word because now we talk about linear algebra. One of
the pieces of this cosine similarity is the magnitude of the
Of the vector, which I'm going to show in a second, but this is the solution
is the solution clear. First of all before I show you the solution to this.
Before I show you the magnitude very quickly.
Is it clear?
So now you're adding.
declare
declare a fourth vector.
That is the sum.
of vectors
one two three
if it's clear type in C.
Otherwise, let me know if you have any questions.
previously the answer
No, if the answer is clear if you understood the code type. Oh,
no, it's I now can see it now one more thing.
I can understand that maybe the linearity part
would be easy but maybe for the program meaning you need some practice.
What I'm going to do is I'm also going to attach a Python tutorial
from the
From the other course, it's very short. I think.
In about 30 minutes, I go over data structures
in Python. So there's one very basic
tutorial that starts from the very
like from scratch like print function.
But like really basics of python and then
there is one more comprehensive one that goes into the daily structures.
I'll attach both of the dashboard. So maybe
it might it will help you if you review those. So if you if you
know, you kind of have to work your way around this code watch those
videos and hopefully you be
Prepared for this next Workshop. Anyway, let me download this so
this is the solution to
exercise one solution
to exercise one
file download
py
here we go solution to
exercise
one
Okay.
the only three minutes left, so let me talk about let me quickly show you the
magnitude thing and then
we'll talk about what we'll do for the next session.
so coming back here to
our tutorial
magnitude is pretty straightforward.
you
Say you have a vector.
We have a given a vector.
I'm just gonna call this V.
I can mold.
with
four elements
one five three
two just random numbers
then the magnitude
the magnet
ude of the
vector
is denoted
as follows
so it's just two vertical bars.
And how do you evaluate it? We take the square root.
of all the elements of this
of all the elements components points again. These words are
interchangeable of the set V. So we have how many
components we have four components in here. So
we will Square all of them.
Add them all up.
take the square root of
whatever this expression evaluates to and that gives
us the magnitude.
With respect to cosine similarity. There's of course
the cosine function. I will add some reading
materials some
review material for trigonometry
now one of the really what
I found helpful with trigonometry remembering
What sign is what cosine is is not that?
That mnemonic, you know so Kato, I don't like mnemonics. I
like to know why why is side cold side.
First of all of all these words that one can use why sign?
so this is the wood side particular in particular has a
interesting history
The word has got has been let's say
butchered.
It actually has been b*******. It has gone from
it one particular word in Indian it then it
has been mistranslated to
Arabic
or it was correctly translated Arabic but miss translated to Latin.
And we are here. We are here where we have these words like sign
cosine and these words don't have any intuitive meaning
but I'll I'll
others a separate material
Ron ask is there an indeed in the
array method for magnitude?
Yes, I don't remember the method though one by
the way, one of the helpful things you can do with a something
like colab or vs code, which I'll tell
you how to install it. By the way is if you hit the button.
Yeah, the all of the methods that apply
to a numpy object will appear here.
so for magnitude
I don't remember I'd have to
look it up.
By the way, I have to look at reference code when I do these exactly there's
no way I can remember everything.
Here, so there is the mean if you want to Value the mean the
maximum minimum values.
I can flatten it. So if you want to go from if you want to
transform from a matrix to a vector you can do it.
Magnitude. Okay. So let me just say magnitude.
a vector in numpy
directly from the
See ideally you should see this from the numpy.
It's an attribute.
or a method
Anyway, I'll have to look it up. I'll look it up. And anyway,
we'll look at the examples. Yeah, I tried
Norm.
And before is this a list or is it a python? Is
it? No, it's it's a numpy array.
Anyway, we'll look at examples of this.
I look it up normally.
Okay, maybe it's actually NP dot Norm.
And then V4. Maybe it's supposed to be that way.
Beautiful. It's not even that.
I'll look it up. Okay everybody.
The the first assignment will be posted on dashboard.
So the the recording from
Session 1 this recording the tutorials are we
just looked at obviously, there's a tutorial for abstract algebra,
which is the what we talked about today. So just
keep in mind now the assignments will be due.
In the subsequent model so assignments from module one
will be doing module 2.
assignments for module 2 with the do
when module 3 so when the third week starts, okay. Just keep
that in mind, please.
And as if you have any if you have any questions about
what we covered or subsequent classes.
Do let me know on stock.
Yeah, you know what? I'll check this out and I'll add other
comment here comment here commenting here. Okay. Thank you.
Everybody. Enjoy the rest of your day, and I hope to see you on
Friday.
For now. Take care. Bye.